mais pour démarrer ils sont devenus
l'ennemi rural numéro 1 des chasseurs
eux ce sont les sangliers peu nombreux
dans les années 70 il serait aujourd'hui
près d'un million dans nos campagnes une
prolifération qui engendre des
collisions routières des retournements
de terrain et parfois même des accidents
plus graves avveignier une septuagénère
s'est fait percuter par l'un de ses
mammifères dans son jardin ce weekend
bilan de multiples fractures Lucas
Chopin et Roméo marm se sont rendus sur
place pour mieux comprendre le contexte
de cet
accident c'est dans ce quartier calme du
nord de veignier qu'un sanglier a semé
la désolation samedi matin des chasseur
effectue une battue et l'animal d'une
centaine de kilos pénètre dans un jardin
celui de Janine la dame âgée n'a pas le
temps de réagir le sanglier lui saute
dessus et s'en prend à elle heureusement
Marie Noël sa voisine alertée par les
cris vol à son secours j'ai entendu
crier ma voisine j'ai regardé par la
fenêtre et j'ai vu qu'elle était
attaquée par un énorme sanglier euh ben
j'ai eu très peur j'ai ouvert la fenêtre
j'ai crié pour le faire fuir
heureusement il est parti et après ben
j'ai pu aller la voir pour appeler les
pompiers et cetera le sanglier prend
alors la fuite dans un autre jardin
juste derrière moi et se bat avec Oslo
un Rotweiler aujourd'hui l'animal laisse
derrière lui un quartier sous le choc il
se balade il défonce tout ça c'est s des
jardins et tout ça il défonce tout mais
attaquer quelqu'un parce que si elle a
d'après ce que j'ai compris elle aurait
elle aurait pas appelé les voisins truc
comme ça il a tué le sanglier cette dame
là est tellement gentille ça fait mal au
cœur selon le maire de veignier si les
sangliers ne sont pas rares ici la
violence des fait interpelle jusqu'ici
ces animaux ne s'en prenaient qu'à du
matériel il faut faire comprendre aux
citoyens qu' sont contre la chasse qui
sont
contre tout ce qu'on peut mener comme
action dans dans ce sens de dire ben
ainsi on en a besoin de de régulation
euh et puis euh ben faire comprendre
aussi au chasseurs que ben il faut pas
trop s'approcher des maisons alors que
le sanglier lui a tout à fait compris
qu'il était en sécurité dans les jardins
des des maisons désormais l'heure est à
la recherche de solution une solution à
laquelle les chasseurs pourraient être
mêlés